the new Miss Universe is
[Music]
20:19 s new Miss Universe is o Sabini
tunze was crowned Sunday night
[Music]
and the pageant was filled with some
standout moments as contestants from
more than 90 countries participated and
audiences from all over the world tuned
in to the three-hour broadcast the new
Miss Universe
[Music]
[Applause]
the 26 year old winner has taken over
the role from the previous Miss Universe
Catriona gray of the Philippines Steve
Harvey returned to host the event for
the fifth year in a row if you told me
five years ago I was going to still be
here
Ida thought she was crazy too but I made
it I survived it all and a ceremony was
held at the recently opened Tyler Perry
studios in Atlanta the event featured
concert performances from Ally Brooke
and I love Selena so it feels pretty
unbelievable
honestly who opened the show and later
paid tribute to her idol selena
quintanilla with an emotional rendition
of I could fall in love and dreaming of
you during the evening gown portion of
the competition
[Music]
south africa should be feeling extra
proud tonight as another contestant from
the country also won the title just two
years ago in 2017 congratulations to
Miss Universe 2019
[Music]